la rentrée des facultés claveau logique
est marquée cette année par une
réception dans le grade de docteur
la biologiste causa de l'académicien
marcel achard monsieur marcel achard est
d'origine lyonnaise puisqu'il est né à
sainte foy les lyon et une de ses pièces
la dame en blanc est actuellement
l'affiché du théâtre des célestins à
lyon
la cérémonie traditionnelle placée sous
la présidence du collège magistrale des
rites de l'ordre du cloud dirigé par son
grand chancelier benoît se déroule en
présence de nombreuses personnalités et
notamment de nous deux seuls vrais férus
de représentant monsieur le préfet de
région et da représentant monsieur
pradel monsieur à perdre monsieur le
grand chancelier venait d'accomplir les
rites d'une intronisation et qui
souligne l'importance du cloud pour
votre illustre compagnie quel sens
profond devons nous accorder à ce
symbole les biens l'institut des
sciences biologiques à savoir destinée à
assurer le rayonnement relance du cloud
a été fondée en 1952
tout fan de récompenser aux fins de
souligner la valeur tout ce qui alliant
défendent l'humour sous toutes ses
formes très connus on a souvent une
réputation qui paraît fâcheuse à
d'aucuns alors qu'en réalité c'est une
réserve inépuisable de gagnant 10 depuis
laurent mourguet bien d'autres encore
dans ces conditions d'ordre plus à une
vocation bien déterminer celle d'une
défense militante et active de l'ue nous
c'est ce qui explique qu'avec une
réserve d'une discrétion qui te
lyonnaise il a installé son siège à 7
mètres cinquante sutter ne serait ce que
pour justifier certaines opinions qui
disait que lyon quelquefois avait le
sourire d'une humide et plaintif joconde
mais en fait d'humidité à l'ordre du
cloud nous donnons à tous l'absolution
avec un excellent beaujolais monsieur
marcel achard et donc depuis quelques
instants dr claveau logies causa il a
magistralement satisfait aux épreuves du
cloud et son allocution à illustrer
l'attachement du plus spirituelle des
académiciens à l'humour en général et à
l'humour lyonnais en particulier m
j'irai plus loin si vous le permettez
que pensez-vous du canular et du canular
ota
eh bien écoutez le canular au tchad n'a
jamais fait beaucoup d'effet c'est la
seule la réussite est encore peut-on
appeler ça une réussite passée étudiants
et surtout une réussite de livres la
seule réussite raël du canular c'est
jelle père ubu destin en revue est
beaucoup plus drôle la nourriture qu'il
ne l'est à la réalisation et leurs
avertissements n'étaient bien su
durement attendri il s'est fait étriller
que la blague il ne met pas mal fait son
travail mais c'est une maille qui ne
peut pas passer qui n'est pas valable
pour 20 millions de dhs il n'y a pas
même prêt d'union tic qui sont dans dans
le secret d'une plaisanterie vous
comprenez c'est le les lis les indiens
sioux les disons même allons jusqu'à
dire une chose aux profanes et qui est
prête et bat l'aspect battoir même les
chrétiens dans les catacombes avait un
mot de passe était qu'ils n'étaient pas
compensée pour les autres comprenez ce
que je veux dire il y a
dans la blague dans le cadre d'un
quelque chose qui échappe à tous et qui
est même quand il est transporté dans
quelque chose de sacré n'est pas
compréhensible de tout le monde